This is special effects
legend Kevin Yagher.
And here, he's adding some color
to the nipple of this fake bodysuit.
But as he moves the airbrush up,
he's adding a much more subtle change.
You can see the difference
between the bottom of the suit
and the top part that
he hasn't gotten to yet.
What this spray paint does
is give the suit texture,
mimicking the undertones
human skin naturally has
and giving the appearance
of tiny details like pores.
From a life cast picking up on
an actor's defining features
to sculpting subtle veins
to mastering a jiggly stomach,
a lot of effort goes into making
the bodysuits actors wear look realistic.
Warning: Some spoilers ahead
for "Bill & Ted Face the Music."
Bodysuits let actors go through
physical transformations
that they couldn't
easily make on their own,
from gaining weight to gaining
muscle to being pregnant.
There are times when bodysuits
don't need to be as detailed
because they're covered in clothing,
like this suit Kevin Yagher
designed for Dana Carvey
in an ultimately cut sequence
from "The Master of Disguise."
But because Keanu Reeves and Alex Winter
appear shirtless in "Bill
& Ted Face the Music,"
both the muscle suits and fat bodysuit
created for scenes where they meet
future versions of themselves
had to be incredibly detailed.
To make a bodysuit, you first have to get
a life cast of an actor's entire torso.
Narrator: Keanu and Alex were covered
in purple and green silicone rubbers.
The green silicone has an oil in it
that ensures it won't pull
any of the actors' hairs
out of their bodies.
The two silicones adhere to each other
and are then wrapped in a
temporary plaster jacket
to hold them together,
which will eventually be
replaced by a fiberglass shell.
That forms the mold that
will shape the bodysuits.
The fiberglass torso shell is laid up
into the silicone impression,
which then gets covered in clay
for the sculpting part of the process.
This is the first stage where attention
to every realistic detail is crucial,
as the team sculpts every
muscle and vein onto this mold.
Kevin Yagher: I just wanted
to make sure it looked,
at every angle, like if he
lifted his arm or something,
that everything was finished
beautifully down here
just as much as it was up here.
Narrator: In early design
and Photoshop stages,
Alex said he actually
wanted the muscular Bill
to look like a gorilla.
Even if the suit's shape is over the top,
the basic anatomy can still be convincing.
Sculptor Carol Koch kept a
model of the human anatomy
in front of her as a reference
while chipping away at the muscle suits.
Kevin says a common misconception is that
when muscles bulge, the veins will too,
but veins actually don't get that big.
Kevin: I would have them just keep making
those veins subtle, more subtle.
So they would just keep smoothing them out
until I could barely see them,
where they're there, but
they didn't look, you know,
like if they were worms.
And then when I come back with a painting,
that also pops them up,
so the combination of a
nice sculpture with paint
is what makes them look real.
Narrator: Once they've sculpted the shape
of the bodysuits with all
their details in clay,
they make a mold of the clay
suit using a thicker silicone,
combine the life cast torso shell,
and then inject foam latex into it.
The outer layer of foam
is removed and replaced
with a skin-colored layer of silicone.
What about silicone makes
it the right material
for human skin?
Well, foam wrinkles easily,
and silicone can soften those wrinkles.
But more importantly, Kevin says,
silicone absorbs light the
same way human skin does,
which goes a long way towards
making the suits look real.
But it isn't until
after the suit is sealed
and injected with yet more silicone
that Kevin can start to
paint details on the skin,
as plain foam doesn't look very convincing
as an outer skin layer.
The next thing to nail was skin tone.
When trying to nail the color
palette of the actors' skin,
Kevin started with lighter shades
to match Keanu and Alex's complexions.
But the prison scene in "Face the Music"
was shot in New Orleans during July,
when temperatures reached
nearly 100 degrees Fahrenheit.
And the scene with the muscle suits
was shot in a prison yard,
so Kevin knew the actors would be spending
a lot of time in the sun.
So to compensate, he made the suits
a shade darker than
their normal skin tone.
Or, as Kevin says,
he "gave the suits a suntan."
Which gets to an important point.
Color makes a big difference
in making the skin look real.
Take a look at the muscle suits
during a nearly completed stage.
The abs pop out not just
because of how they're sculpted,
but because of how they're colored.
The team used an unexpected
color combination
of red and green paint
underneath and around each ab.
It's those kinds of surprising
details in human skin
that only an artist can detect.
Let's go back into that
blank area of the muscle suit
he colored in with an airbrush.
Kevin says there's always
some red in a person's skin.
So he starts with that red base
and then adds shades of green and blue,
other colors he's observed in the skin.
Kevin: I use a very
tiny, tiny little spray.
So, it only maybe puts out, oh,
a 16th of an inch a band of color.
I do this thing, for some
reason I call it wobbly hand,
and I just kind of
create a kind of wobble,
and I also go in and out.
So I'm constantly moving
my hand like this,
and then I'm going in and
out, you know, to the thing.
It causes little dots;
it causes little veins; a little breakup.
Narrator: While that is happening,
the left nipple doesn't fully pass
until a pinkish-brown
coat gets sprayed on it.
The muscle suits were smooth and hairless
to mimic bodybuilders, but
Keanu's fat suit had hair.
Adding hair to a suit makes it
easier to hide skin details,
but each hair has to look real,
from how it curls to the growth pattern.
Kevin punched at least
300 individual hairs
into the stomach and chest
of Keanu's fake paunch.
He made sure to make the
hair thicker and heavier
as it went down the
chest towards the groin.
Kevin's work isn't only
about painting splotches
and punching hairs.
You can't have a bodysuit
that just looks realistic.
It also has to move like a real body.
The foam latex beneath the
layer of skin-like silicone
helps the actors move comfortably.
A fat suit, like the one
Kevin made for Keanu,
needs to bounce and jiggle naturally.
You can see that as Keanu's
stomach pops out of his shirt
during this shot in the film.
So, how do you make it move
while also giving it some weight?
The classic technique?
Stuffing the suit with dry lentils.
Kevin used them when building the suit
for Weird Al Yankovic's
1988 music video "Fat."
He later created two body
pieces to add 40 pounds
to Nicolas Cage in 2002's "Adaptation."
This time around, Kevin
tried to achieve movement
in one of them by mixing lentils and beads
into one of his suits,
but the actor's sweat
actually caused the lentils to sprout.
So now, to get the movement
and weight without the mess,
Kevin simply fills the
chest and stomach of a suit
with bags of beads.
Kevin: It kinda jiggles up and down.
Narrator: With all the skill involved
in making these suits look and
move like real human flesh,
some of the realism is achieved
by cleverly hiding the dead giveaways.
Makeup artists typically
cover up the zippers
on the back of bodysuits,
but because of that
brutal New Orleans heat,
they kept the zippers on
the muscle suits exposed
so the actors could hop in and out of them
quickly to cool off.
So for a shot like this, the
zippers were just CGI'd out.
Kevin also needed to hide the seams
where the suit connects to real skin
around the neck and the arms.
So when wearing the muscle suits,
the two actors wore weight-lifting gloves,
while Keanu's long fake
beard hid the neck seam.
You will also notice Keanu
wearing two necklaces
in the shots where he has a bigger belly.
The lower one was glued
down to hide the straps
that held the suit up above the chest.
For one final touch of realism,
Kevin applied a water and glycerin mix
to Keanu and Alex's prison bodysuits
to give off a persuasively sweaty look.
All that effort, from
punching hundreds of hairs
to wearing a 20- to 25-pound
suit in punishing heat,
created something realistic
not just for the viewer,
but also the actor.
Kevin: Alex Winter liked
to have all that weight,
because it helped him in his acting
to have enough girth on him
to kind of perform better.
He was happy with that.